this video is brought to you by under
luckystars.com
[Music]
chuck you know i have history with the
titanic uh hopefully that history
is not you were on it let's hope that
you know there's a joke about uh the day
we invent a
time machine right you want to ask well
what historical event will people most
want to observe
and the number one is the sinking of the
titanic and so
i'm a carb well i know it's totally
macabre but
the way the argument goes the titanic
sank
because so many people time travel back
to it
to see it that's what caused it that's
very funny
so i have history because the movie made
by james cameron right uh back in the
1990s i saw it in real time
right and when the ship sank spoiler
alert
the uh there's rose on a plank looking
up at the night sky there was
no moon no clouds right in the in the
north atlanta it was a black sky
well other than the stars so we know
everything about the night sky
when the ship sank and she looks up and
there's her point of view
and it's the wrong sky i saw this admit
immediately
i'm in the theater you're sitting in the
theater yes yes
leo dicaprio is freezing to death on a
boat
well he's dead and she's looking up at
the sky
and you see this guy and go that is the
wrong sky now i wouldn't have an issue
with it except the entire marketing for
the movie
was how accurate things were he went to
the bottom of the ocean with robert
ballard a great oceanographer
and they found the titanic and they know
where the rivets are the state
rooms the china patterns right all of
that right and they duplicated that
now you can't do that you can't even
duplicate the night sky i know you
you can't verify the china patterns in a
thing you're just trusting him on that
right but i can verify the night sky and
he got the wrong night's
not only that it was a lazy sky what's a
lazy sky
the left side of the sky was a mirror
reflection of the right side
so they are so basically they were like
half the sky is good enough let's flip
this over
i would later learn interestingly that
there was a reason for that
why because they only made half a ship
and in
in cg and then yeah so the
duplicating one half became just a thing
they could do right and they just did it
with the sky
yeah all right so i wrote to jim back
then
no i got no my finest letterhead hair
doctor tyson
planetary museum i got no reply but
years later
dear mr cameron uh uh albeit i am a fan
of your work your lazy sky
sucks so i so i then
i i a few years later i would bump into
him because i was serving on the board
of nasa
and he was on some committee right and
we there was a conference and we met and
i said
mr cameron have you uh uh did you get my
letter did you get my letter he said no
about retold he said you know that was
done in post-production
you know i wanted him to like grovel at
my feet no and
so no he was like well i had nothing to
do i had none to do it i said you the
head of the damn project right
so years later he's given an award here
there's a there's an organization
renting this museum space at night
to give him an award and they gave me a
courtesy invite and i said well sure is
james cameron going to be there they
said yeah
and would you like to come to dinner
afterwards just a small group i said is
james cameron going to be
he said yes will his chef be as lazy as
his sky
so i go there and i tell him this all
again and he says well last night check
titanic has grossed a billion dollars
worldwide
imagine how much more it would have
grossed had i gotten the sky
correct it was like oh
burn burn two weeks later he called
someone i got a phone call he says uh
hello this is dr tyson i said yes i
forgot his name johnny smith
i i worked post-production for james
cameron uh-oh
and he's uh uh-oh and he said james
cameron is producing a centennial
director's cut
oh sweet and he's re-cutting some of the
scenes and he tells me you have a sky
he could use oh oh oh
yo that's hot yo so wait a minute
so i created the sky and he put it in
his thing
okay then i found out there's a whole
company
that will you tell them what sky you
wanted at a moment and they went ahead
and did that so i looked at the this was
the sinking of the rms titanic and this
resembles the sky that i gave him
okay this is done in reverse obviously
right because the sky is white
and the stars are black but i gave him i
gave him the map and this is the milky
way coming through
this is directly over rose's head right
when she's looking up
deliriously right and i told him i said
this is less interesting than where the
milky way is
so if you want to put it over a little
bit i'm okay with that right that's
slightly distorted
but it's but we're cool it's still
within the bounds of acceptability
yeah so to me the titanic is all about
death and
and disaster but apparently it means
something different to you it's a love
story yes
a love story so is braveheart but listen
i'm not going there
okay titanic's not a love story it is uh
uh jim cameron's movie is a love story
folded onto a disaster oh my
oh you didn't know there was a disaster
going on you were just all touched
i was blinded by love you overclamped
that's right
but listen that's what made it even more
romantic
is that you know it was going on on top
of the top of it like you can find love
anywhere that's true even in a disaster
even on a sinking
ship you can find love did you tell me
you did something like this
with your wife so what i did was the
actual night that my wife and i met in
philadelphia
the sky above that location i got that
actual sky
put into that heart with the message
your heart is my universe what what so
you can do that feeling the universe
before you had any connection to star
trek
connection oh this is what i'm putting
it was destiny your heart is my universe
so and that's what's cool about this is
that whatever message that you were so
for you it's the sinking of the rms
this particular this particular case but
you can put whatever message you want
right you could commemorate whatever
date you want whatever occasion you want
and then take a rose could say the night
i killed
jack that could be rose it's just like
the night i killed this guy
the night i shoved him off my plank how
romantic
and then dropped a million dollar thing
into the ocean yeah yeah
so if you want to impress your life
partner and i mean in such a way that uh
it comes with shall i say rewards
it ups the level of romance up the level
of rome
take it up a notch look at that that was
very romantic of you right there i'm
just saying
take it up take your romance up a notch
okay go ahead and commemorate a moment
celestia it wouldn't have to be when
you're mad it could be no it could be
anything
when you took that romantic walk on the
beach there you go right right our first
night out at the movies
all right the night we got married you
know anything the birth of our first
child because we don't like the rest of
them
and everybody knows what minute their
child was born so you put that into the
minute yeah
everybody knows what time were you
unless you were really long
you got me with that one that's what i'm
saying
no matter what the moment is under lucky
stars has a sky
for you that's my point under
luckystars.com go ahead and do it
okay by the way i got you one too oh i'm
serious
i'm not gonna show it to you now you can
make your own star map by going to
under luckystars.com they've been in
business since 2016 making them the
first custom star map maker
a star map is a great way to commemorate
important events
like when you first met your sweetheart
birthdays engagements weddings and more
choose the date customize the title and
select your design
also and this is important for star talk
fans the maps have been verified by a
nasa astronomer for accuracy
which you can read all about on under
luckystars.com
don't wait go to underluckystars.com
today and order right away
and you could have your star map in time
for valentine's day